geschätzte damen und herren werte
medienvertreterinnen und medienvertreter
zu hause und hier im festsaal ich dass
sie recht herzlich zur pressekonferenz
zum thema paralympischen sommerspiele 20
21 tokio und gleichstellung begrüßen
ich darf gleichzeitig an einem ganz
besonderen kollegen herrn andreas und er
übergeben der sie durch die
veranstaltung führen wird
herzlichen dank oberste ob man meine
damen und herren herzlich willkommen ich
freue mich sehr dass ich sie heute ein
bisschen begleiten darf durch diese
pressekonferenz
frau bundesministerin freuen uns sehr
dass sie hier sind frau präsidentin des
pcs auch ansehen herzlich willkommen und
auch an oberster christian kramer
herzlich willkommen kommandant der herr
sportzentrum hier am podium
sie haben es schon angesprochen gehört
ich stehe zum ersten mal in einer grünen
uniform im kampfanzug 03 vor ihnen und
was es damit auf sich hat was das alles
bedeutet für den österreichischen der
behindertensport das wären wir heute
alles erfahren wir freuen uns auf jeden
fall dass sie mit dabei sind das auch
meine kolleginnen und kollegen aus dem
heraus sportzentrum hier sind und viele
menschen die an diesem prozess beteiligt
waren dass im hinblick auf die
paralympics in tokio diese
gleichstellung vorangetrieben wird im
österreichischen bundesheer
jetzt will ich doch sagen wir machen
gleich weiter mit der pressekonferenz
und darf die frau bundesministerin um
ihre begrüßungsworte bitten
oberst sehr geehrte damen und herren der
medien diese sportlerinnen und sportler
ich darf sie alle herzlich im
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
begrüßen das heutige thema hat für uns
im bundesheer und im ressort für mich
persönlich aber eine ganz besondere
bedeutung auch die völlige
gleichstellung von gehandicapten
sportlerinnen und sportlern des jahres
sportzentrums ich glaube dieses thema
das kann man nicht ohne die
bevorstehenden paraolympischen spiele
betrachten weil das bundesheer über das
sportzentrum als seine sportkompetenz
einfließen lässt damit österreichische
sportlerinnen und sportler möglichst
viele internationale sport erfolge
erringen können
ich bin wirklich sehr dankbar dass wir
in großartiger weise gemeinsam mit dem
österreichischen olympischen komitee im
fachlichen austausch sind und dass das
hehre sportzentrum mehr als 50% des team
austria für tokio stellen wird
aus diesem grund darf ich heute die
präsidentin des paralympischen komitees
von bundesministerin außer dienst maria
rauch kallat ganz besonders herzlich
hier begrüßen
ja gemeinsam miteinander haben wir zu
diesem termin eingeladen weil wir nur
gemeinsam die erfolge erzielen und
erringen können die sich österreich die
wir uns von unseren athletinnen und
athleten erhoffen ihres weiteren darf
ich ihnen vorstellen herrn oberst
christian ganter kommandant des heeres
sportzentrums der damit auch kommandant
von 450 top athletinnen und athleten ist
und somit von zahlreichen olympia
medaillengewinnerinnen weltmeistern
weltcupsiegen und nachwuchshoffnungen
ist ja und wie wir ihn er ich glaube ich
habe ein wenig an arbeit ihnen jetzt
schon abnehmen können als moderator
nicht nur
als moderator ist er heute hier sondern
er ist ja auch der großartige host des
bundes ereignen und sehr hörenswerten
sport podcast spart rapport ich darf
dich jetzt der geht es ab der das event
in liebe maria um deine ausführungen
bieten
sehr geehrte frau bundesminister danner
sehr geehrte oberst kramer nicht mehr
sportlerinnen und sportler die sich
jetzt schon vorbereiten sehr geehrte
damen und herren
zunächst einmal möchte ich mich bedanken
bedanken dass wir heute hier sein dürfen
bedanken für den grund warum wir heute
hier sein dürfen und den anlass weil für
uns ist das wirklich ein meilenstein für
die paralympische bewegung ist dieser
schritt zur totalen absoluten
gleichstellung ein ganz ganz wichtiger
schritt
es ist ein system aufbruch wie es schon
viele gegeben hatte ich erinnere mich
1995 als wir darum gekämpft haben dass
frauen zum bundesheer kommen dürfen
und es war 2006 glaube ich als ich den
damaligen leiter des heeres sports
gefragt habe ob es nicht möglich wäre
das vielleicht unsere athletinnen und
athleten auch in den herzsport
aufgenommen werden und die antwort
bekommen ist völlig unmöglich also das
wie stellen sie sich das vor die sind ja
behindert solle und was haben sie damals
mit ihren kriegsinvaliden gemacht haben
sie die nach hause geschickt nachdem sie
sich für das vaterland geopfert haben
es ist schön dass wir dann immerhin nach
zehn jahren 2016 nach den sommerspielen
in rio de janeiro die ersten fünf
heeressportler vorstellen durften in der
südstadt war das damals 2017 wurde
dieses projekt aufgestockt auf 20 plätze
im heeres sport so dass sich 20
paralympische athletinnen und athleten
und solche die es noch werden wollten
vorbereiten konnten ihn zu den gleichen
bedingungen
die olympia teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer und das war ein ganz ganz
wichtiger schritt
und jetzt geht das hermes ministerium
und dafür gilt mein besonderer dank noch
einen schritt weiter nämlich in die
vollkommene gleichstellung zu werden
seite hören
das wird nicht nur etwas mit der uniform
zu tun aber auch dass das hat in der
vorbereitung sehr gut andreas anne und
her schon gesagt das ist etwas anderes
wenn wir mit der uniform neben den
anderen heeressportler und stehen und
nicht in unseren roten trainingsanzügen
und man soll das nicht zu unterschätzen
ich weiß wie wichtig dass sie sich auch
selbst eine blinde tochter die sport
betrieben hat und für die dieser sport
immer ganz ganz und immer noch betreibt
und für die dieser sport ganz ganz
wichtig ist das österreichische
bundesheer ist für uns ein ganz ganz
wichtiger partner weil sie jetzt diesen
athletinnen und athleten auch eine
perspektive eine zukunftsperspektive
anbietet sie werden das im detail dann
hören aber es ist für jeden sport der
für jede sportlerin wichtig dass sie
nach ihrer karriere dann nicht ins
bodenlose fällt sondern dass es hier
eine absicherung gibt und die
möglichkeit hier sich auch abgesichert
zu fühlen ist glaube ich für jeden in
unserem land ganz ganz wichtig wir sind
kurz vor den spielen in tokio
sie werden gott sei dank stattfinden es
werden ganz besondere spiele seien ohne
fans ohne angehörige die mitreisen
dürfen aber wir hoffen doch sehr dass
sie stattfinden wir glauben fest daran
und unsere athletinnen und athleten
haben sich jetzt ein jahr länger darauf
vorbereitet dafür qualifiziert wir
rechnen mit einem team von rund 30
athletinnen und athleten und hoffen dass
wir mit vielen medaillen zurückkommen
danke nochmals frau bundesministerin
danke dem heeres ministerium und allen
die daran beteiligt waren dass das heute
möglich ist
braucht präsidentin für das statement
seitens des österreichischen
paralympischen komitee und was sich
getan hat seit dieser öffnung die 2016
erfolgt ist und wird die gleichstellung
voranschreitet dafür freue ich mich dass
ich jetzt ein statement unserer frau
bundesministerin von seitens des
verteidigungsministeriums sie gerne
darum bitten darf
vielen dank und er vor allem aber auch
hier frau präsidentin ein ganz großes
dankeschön für diese so lobenden worte
sehr geehrte damen und herren das
österreichische bundesheer wir haben uns
in den vergangenen jahren wohl es sehr
große wenn ich die größten förderer des
heimischen leistungssportlers etabliert
und ich denke die heutige präsentation
des kaders beweist einmal mehr die
hervorragenden leistungen der
sportlerinnen und sportler unsere serie
sportzentrums herr oberster kramer wird
dann ja später im detail noch darauf
eingehen wir haben aktuell acht jahre
sportlerinnen und sportler schon fix für
tokio qualifiziert und weitere vier
jahres bedienstete haben sich schon
qualifiziert und warten jetzt aber noch
auf die quoten vergabe ja und zwei
unserer athleten kämpfen derzeit noch um
die qualifikation
besonders stolz bin ich am heutigen tag
auf unsere neuerungen die denke ich uns
das österreichische bundesheer zu einem
vorreiter machen zu einem vorreiter der
gleichstellung im behinderten
leistungssport es ist mehrfach schon
angesprochen worden das bundesheer
begann 2016 mit 20 arbeitsplätzen für
sportlerinnen und sportler mit
behinderung das war ein sehr wichtiger
schritt der aber befristet vorrangig auf
vier jahre also bis zu den
paraolympischen spielen im jahr 2020
ausgelegt allein schon die verschiebung
der spiele in tokio hat uns dann bewogen
die verträge mit unseren harris athleten
mit handicap um ein jahr
zu verlängern aber ich sage auch ganz
offen das war mir das war uns nicht
genug und daher sind wir den glaube ich
wirklich ganz wichtigen schritt der
völligen gleichstellung mit den
sportlerinnen und sportlern ohne
handicap gegangen beziehungsweise haben
den diesen veranlasst wir haben neue
vertrags möglichkeiten jetzt für unsere
sportlerinnen und sportler die aktuell
beim heer beschäftigt sind sie können
als zivile vertragsbedienstete oder eben
als militär person in uniform ihren
dienst weiter fortsetzen
die möglichkeit des dienstes als monetär
person ermöglicht den athleten während
oder anschließend an den vertrag eine
berufs förderung in anspruch nehmen zu
können
das erlangte know how das soll dann auch
die grundlage sein zukünftig die
athleten nach ihrer aktiven karriere
weiter bei uns im resort zu beschäftigen
diejenigen athleten den athleten mit
einem alter über dem vierzigsten
lebensjahr können weiterhin beim
bundesheer aufgenommen werden und ihren
dienst als zivilbedienstete erfüllen
das ist eine wichtige grundlage es ist
aber auch eine rechtlich verankerte
grundlage die wir geschaffen haben und
die es uns flexibel ermöglicht dass wir
wirklich maßgeschneiderte lösungen
schaffen um auf die jeweiligen
individuellen und sozialen natürlich
auch sportlichen bedürfnisse aber auch
die zukunftspläne unsere sportlerinnen
und sportler einzugehen
ich kann mit stolz sagen dass wir im
österreichischen bundesheer vor reit der
vorbild sind in der gleichstellung in
der inklusion und das ohne zweifel im
internationalen vergleich unsere
behinderten sportlerinnen und sportler
leisten großartiges sie verdienen sich
die beste die bestmögliche unterstützung
die es nur geben kann und das können wir
mit dieser innovativen
maßnahme des personalmanagements ihm her
auch gewährleisten
herzlichen dank frau bundesministerin
ich kann bestätigen was jetzt gesagt
haben wenn ich auf internationalen
wettkämpfen unterwegs bin und mit meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen rede und sie
nach dem system in österreich fragen
dann schauen alle mit neid zu uns dass
wir da heraus patienten unterkunft
gefunden haben und so gut unterstützt
werden also herzlichen dank dafür und
auch für die neuerungen und im detail
wie die neuerungen nun auch schon werden
wie sie sich auswirken werden auf die
bestehenden her dass der sportlerinnen
und sportler und auch für die
zukünftigen talente und top athletinnen
und athleten die wir noch aufnehmen
werden da freue ich mich dass oberster
christian kramer kommandanten
sportzentrum uns nun sein statement
geben wird sehr geehrte frau
bundesministerin sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich darf nun die details
vorstellen zur gleichstellung aller
bundesheer leistungssportlerinnen und
leistungssportler innerhalb des
österreichischen ungefähres die
leistungssport förderung im herzzentrum
ist so organisiert dass wir 20
arbeitsplätze für leistungssportler und
leistungssportler mit behinderung haben
die auf einer basis als
vertragsbedienstete bei uns angestellt
sind also als zivilbedienstete daneben
gibt es im regel sport 280 weitere
arbeitsplätze und hier ist es so dass
diese bediensteten als militärpersonen
auf zeit also als soldatinnen und
soldaten angestellt sind und hier noch
anzumerken wäre und das ist auch ganz
wichtig dass mit 20 16 und es wurde ja
schon erwähnt der erste große wurf
gelungen ist sportler mit besonderen
bedürfnissen mal in der system bundes
als leistungssportler hinein zu bringen
um zu etablieren
allerdings war es ursprünglich so
angedacht dass diese aufnahme für einen
olympia zyklus erfolgen soll oder für
einen paralympics zirkus für vier jahre
und eine weitere verlängerung wäre
gemäss diesem vertragswerk nicht möglich
gewesen
umso schöner ist es heute an diesem tag
und umso erfreulicher eben bekannt geben
zu dürfen dass mit der änderung des des
bdg und der verlautbarung im
bundesgesetzblatt 153 aus 20 20
die aufnahme als militär person auf zeit
also als soldat auch
leistungssportlerinnen und
leistungssportler mit behinderung
ermöglicht wird was sind da jetzt die
vorteile also die riesengroßen vorteile
sind wie schon erwähnt dass die
sportlerinnen und sportler nunmehr bis
zu 15 jahre verlängert werden können und
dass bis zum vierzigsten lebensjahr ist
für den leistungssportler und für
leistungssportlerinnen extrem wichtig
weil natürlich in so einem zeitraum das
entwicklungspotenzial viel besser
ausgereizt werden kann
das ist ein riesengroßer vorteil 2000
großer vorteil ist dass jetzt auch eine
berufsförderung analog zu den regel
sportlern auch von den sportlern und
sportlerinnen mit besonderen
bedürfnissen in anspruch genommen werden
kann
bereits während der dienstzeit und auch
danach umso nach der sportlichen
karriere auch bereits für die berufliche
karriere vorzusorgen
und natürlich besteht auch die
möglichkeit im system alle internen
weiterbildungsmaßnahmen wir für
soldatinnen und soldaten zur verfügung
stehen jetzt auch von den bundes der
leistungs sportlerinnen und sportlern
mit besonderen bedürfnissen genutzt
werden und auch bereits erwähnt und das
freut mich außerordentlich man sieht
auch hier es gibt jetzt im jahre
sportzentrum ein einheitliches
erscheinungsbild das heißt alle
leistungssportlerinnen und
leistungssportler werden jetzt in
uniform
in erscheinung treten wie schaut die
konkrete umsetzung aus bei neuaufnahmen
wird sich das so gestalten dass bis zum
vierzigsten lebensjahr
die neuaufnahmen als militär person auf
zeit erfolgen werden über dem
vierzigsten lebensjahr lebensjahr wir
besondere regelungen gegeben haben wie
bisher auch mit einer aufnahme als vw
leistungssportler oder
leistungssportlerin und das abgestimmt
auf die sportlichen zielsetzungen
beziehungsweise auf das sportliche
leistungspotenzial die
übergangsregelungen schauen jetzt so aus
führt die sportler die sich schon im
system befinden und hier sei erwähnt
dass im heurigen jahr also 20 21 bei 16
athletinnen und athleten das
dienstverhältnis auslaufen würde und
acht personen davon sind über den
vierzigsten lebensjahr das prozedere in
der überleitung wird hier konkret so
ausschauen dass die die jünger als 40
sind die möglichkeit haben optional zu
wählen ob sie jetzt die vertragsform
militär person auf zeit wählen oder in
dem dienstverhältnis weiter bleiben und
diejenigen die älter als 40 sind können
wieder im sinne einer sonderregelung mit
abstimmung auf die sportliche
zielsetzung und auf das
leistungspotenzial einen sondervertrag
bekommen
abschließend lassen sie mich bitte auch
noch betonen das ist uns ganz wichtig
dass wir das potenzial der athletinnen
und athleten aller als im regel sport
und im behindertensport für uns im
system natürlich nützen wollen
das sind junge und es freut mich immer
es als als kommandant wenn ich mit den
leistungssportlerinnen und
leistungssportler in kontakt treten kann
sind sehr zielstrebige sehr erfolgreich
junge menschen und von daher ist es
natürlich unser bestreben diesen elan
mit zu uns ins system zu nehmen nicht
als leistungssportler sondern auch als
karriere danach und ist in diesem
zusammenhang haben die bereits karriere
gespräche mit allen athletinnen und
athleten geführt und so ist es möglich
dass für alle eine eine lösung gefunden
werden kann dass sie wenn sie es wollen
auch im system das österreichische
bundesheer als zivilbedienstete und
zivilbediensteten verstärken werden
nunmehr david überleiten und das freut
mich auch außerordentlich weil die
paralympics vor der tür stehen
tokio 20 20 die athletinnen und athleten
des österreichischen bundesheeres
vorzustellen wie die frau
bundesministerin bereits erwähnt hat
haben sie hier acht schon fix
qualifiziert namentlich wären das in der
sportart kano markus roboter in der
leichtathletik
natalia und mareen kräh spiel im
radfahren martin pewal im reiten ski an
kaliber julia im schwimmen ohne andreas
und ehrenhof andreas beziehungsweise im
tischtennis gardos christian und bei
weiteren athleten ist es so dass sie
nach dem heutigen stand qualifiziert
sind
das mit den quoten plätzen ist nicht
immer so einfach ich versuche es einmal
zu erklären es gibt im virtual world
ranking eine grenze die eingezogen wird
bis zu welchem platz man sich für die
olympischen spiele qualifiziert jetzt
laufen natürlich noch einige bewerber
und so kann es sein dass in diesem
ranking der ein oder andere nach vor
oder zurück rutscht aber sehr gut aus
kann ich sagen also aus heutigen stand
qualifiziert nico landmann der aktion
übrigens hat jetzt ein turnier gewonnen
das ist die beste vorbereitung auch was
das metalle betrifft für die parallelen
matzinger günther im triathlon der
ebenso an super wettkampf für zusammen
wochenende in leeds absolviert hat dann
haben wir im radfahren noch quotenplätze
wobei zwei nationen quotenplätze bereits
fix vergeben sind und es kann aber auch
sein dass ein dritter noch dazukommt er
das betrifft dann ab länger weiter
frühwirth thomas und kritsch alexander
die alle drei ebenso letzte woche bei
den europameisterschaften sehr gute
erfolge erzielt haben
noch im qualifikationsmodus befindlich
ist oliver dreier im triathlon
beziehungsweise großhändler im badminton
und scheiber christian im tischtennis
hier besteht noch die chance dass sie
sich qualifizieren
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin das während die
ausführungen seitens des jahres
patienten danke herr kommandant oberst
christian kam es ja mal so gesehen das
hat sich einiges getan es gibt einige
optionen für behinderten sportlerinnen
und behindertensportler und das schöne
ist und das optimale dass man wirklich
individuelle lösungen für die jeweilige
situation sucht der behindertensport ist
einzigartig jeder behinderung ist
einzigartig jede sportlerin und ihrer
sportler sind einzigartig und hier wird
raum und gegeben und eine lösung
gefunden damit jeder sich optimal auf
seinen sport konzentrieren kann und dann
auch dass unsere talente nachhaltig den
österreichischen
verteidigungsministerium genauso zur
verfügung stehen ist auch eine gute
sache die auch ruhe gibt und sicherheit
gibt also ich freue mich sehr über all
diese neuerungen ab der ersten oktober
werden sie nicht nur mich öfter in
dieser uniform sehen sondern auch meine
weiteren kolleginnen und kollegen die
eben auf das system der medizin militär
person auf zeit umsteigen herzlichen
dank für die ausführungen für die
details herzlichen dank auch ihnen für
das regel medieninteresse
ich werde mich jetzt auch bereits machen
um für die interviewanfragen im publikum
dann bereit zu stehen sie haben jetzt
die möglichkeit natürlich unser podium
direkt zu fragen und dafür übergebe ich
auch
wieder an von seiten des ressorts an
oberste obmann dankeschön andreas ich
darf die werten medienvertreterinnen und
medienvertreter ersuchen wenn sie fragen
haben die hand zu heben und ihr medium
und ihren namen zu nennen
ich darf meine kollegin dann ersuchen
dass sie mit dem mikrofon hingeht wenn
sie etwas warten damit man das wirklich
auch von anfang an die frage hört ich
darf um ihre fragen bitten
ja bitte schön die kollegin vom us-fonds
orf ich habe eine frage an sie
ministerin
können sie garantieren dass die
bezahlung die gleiche sein wird und
lasse mich an der zweite noch ergänzen
der anspruch auf berufsförderung
entsteht tatsächlich erst nach dem
vollendeten dritten dienst ja als
militär person
jetzt sind einige paare sportler ja
schon seit 2016 im heeres sport gibt es
da überlegungen wonach vordienstzeiten
angerechnet werden können
vielen dank für diese frage es ist eine
gesetzliche änderung die wir im
beamtendienstrecht jetzt vorgenommen
haben und so die zu einer völligen
gleichstellung führt falls die eine oder
andere frage insbesondere was
vordienstzeiten anbelangt da auch die
zusätzlichen inanspruchnahme von
beratungsangeboten anbelangt dann werden
wir uns das selbstverständlich anschauen
und ich das ziel ist natürlich die
völlige gleichstellung so wie sie im
gesetz auch vorhanden ist sollte es
notwendig sein die eine oder andere
verordnung noch zu adoptieren oder die
interne richtlinie auch noch zu
adaptieren dann werden wir das tun
würden es soll nicht nur ein sichtbares
zeichen sein dass man sozusagen an den
uniformen sieht sondern auch ein
sichtbares zeichen was
weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten was die
frage der bezahlung was die
sozialrechtlichen absicherungen
anbelangt also absolute gleichstellung
das ist unser ziel
dankeschön gibt es weitere fragen aus
dem podium wenn es keine weiteren fragen
mehr gibt dann darf ich mich recht
herzlich bei den zusehern zu hause aber
auch hier im saal werte medienvertreter
bedanken und ich darf die
pressekonferenz für beendet erklären
dankeschön